this is not uh just a policy fight this
is an actual refusal to enforce the laws
that are already on the books these
Democrats know that I really hope that
they have the courage to do the right
thing because it has hurt it's hurt
every American not just Republicans this
has hurt Democrats too that is why you
see many Democrats in South Texas and
along the border region switching from
the Democrat Party to the Republican
party because they don't trust this
Administration and they don't trust
Alejandro
mayorcas a Fox News Alert Congressman
August fluger of the house Homeland
Security committee joining us earlier to
react to the impeachment articles
against DHS secretary Alejandro morcus
which were released just moments ago for
more on this let's bring in the anchor
of Sunday morning Futures Maria Mar bomo
Maria good morning to you Congressman
fluger said to expect a full house vote
on these articles later this week so
this is moving fast where do you think
this is going it sure is carlen good
morning to you we are expecting those
articles of impeachment to come to the
floor on Tuesday so lawmakers can mark
them up one of the blaring obvious
issues here is the number of times
Alejandra mayorcas has told us and here
is the quote there is no crisis the
border is secure we have heard him say
this times and we know that to be not
true one of the issues with President
Biden coming over repeatedly and saying
oh I've known the border is not secure
for 10 years and I need Congress to do
something about it no no no no no the
follow-up question there is then why on
week one of your new Administration back
in 2021 did you reverse all of the deals
that the Trump administration had done
with Guatemala Honduras and El Salvador
and Mexico to stop the traffic at
Mexico's Southern border that is exactly
what this Administration did I spoke
with John Ratcliffe three months into
the new Administration and he said this
is going horribly wrong wrong with these
uh overturns of these agreements that we
put in place and that was the agreements
with Guatemala Honduras El Salvador and
Mexico so it really falls on deaf ears
when Joe Biden says yes the border is no
longer secure and now needs help he
should have been saying that over the
last three years instead he is looking
ahead 280 days away from a a
presidential election knowing that now
immigration has become the number one
issue for voters and now he is saying
that he believed this all the time so
people are not buying it we are getting
a full picture of all of the activity at
the border this morning when I speak
with the uh lieutenant governor of Texas
Dan Patrick coming up in about 40 uh 15
minutes here and then we will also talk
with Carrie Lake getting the Arizona
angle you know Carly the law the uh
border patrol people have told us that
75% of the people that are on the
terrorist watch list stop in Arizona the
goway they go to Tucson Arizona first
car Lake will give us the latest there
and then of course this was the number
one issue for president Trump no wonder
he is soaring in the primaries and the
polls we're going to talk about election
2024 with Kelly and Conway and Dr Ben
Carson Elise japonic is here she is
calling on Governors across the country
to send in their National Guard help
protect Texas help protect America's
sovereignty she is my special guest this
morning we're all live and I'll see you
in about 15 minutes with all of that
Carly an incredible developing story
this morning Maria you got a full show
ahead thank you so much for joining us
have a great day you too I'm Steve juicy
I'm Brian kilme and I'm Angley aart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis